okay so we're back to try harding  instead back again  tell a friend exactly 95  okay  i played a similar line once but  probably okay  i had to address this because someone is  saying isn't this the bank like why did  you call it the greek  but the greek and the bankrupt they  aren't the same opening no can you  explain that uh the i think the the bone  cloud is e4  and then king e2 or  the same moves as black and the greek  is mainly  king  f3 and then king of two but you can  there are also other versions of it  and while explaining this i'm ruining up  my position  so thank you very much  yeah never ask for that again jack  might not be that losing though  here i can go bishop six  if i can just give up  this one i'm fine yeah no i'm fine  i'm gonna win this  game unless i flag of course  brooklyn  oh maybe knight f2 and then i just oh  there's roof d2  it's nice  but yeah knight d2 and i just take  everything  is two back  mate is unstoppable  nice okay